PALLAV MEHTA: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for
attending this session.
My name is Pallav Mehta.
And I'm a product manager
on a Cloud AI team.
And today I'm going to talk
to you about delivering
highly personalized
product recommendations
with recommendations
[INAUDIBLE]..
Later in this
session, we'll also
get to hear from our partners
at BigCommerce and Qubit
about the success they've
had with rolling out
recommendations to
their customers.
To begin with, though,
let's acknowledge
the metaphorical
elephant in the room.
Customer shopping behavior
has changed for good.
With fewer in-store
shopping visits,
retailers have had to shore
up their digital storefronts
and explore new ways
to meaningfully engage
with their customers.
Delivering a superior
customer experience
has become even more
of a differentiator
for the early movers.
And personalized
recommendations have
emerged as one of the strongest
potential drivers of revenue
lift.
But as many retailers
have discovered,
delivering
recommendations at scale
can actually be quite
complex and time consuming.
On the surface, it means
for a given customer
in a given context, deciding
which item to recommend.
But understanding a
customer, especially
if you don't have a
lot of data about them
or their habits frequently
change, can be hard.
Customers also jump
between context
as they mull their
shopping decisions.
And helping them discover
new or poorly cataloged
items in a low-latency
environment
can be especially challenging.
Here at Google, we've
developed smart recommendations
into the magic ingredient that
makes our flagship properties
such a delightful experience.
Google Cloud has packaged
together the best of breed
in deep-learning power
of personalization,
and made it available
to our customers
through Recommendations AI.
Recommendations AI uses
Google's latest machine
learning architectures
which dynamically
adapt to real-time
user behavior, changes,
and variables like a
storefront and pricing.
It's a fully managed
service, so there's
no need to
pre-process your data,
maintain pipelines,
optimize models,
of provision infrastructure
to deliver at scale.
We do it all for
you, automatically.
You simply ingest your
data, retrieve, and display
recommendation results.
You can get up and running fast.
And easy-to-use
graphical interface
can help you
integrate your data,
configure and serve
recommendations,
and monitor system performance.
And recommendations
can be delivered
at sub-hundred [INAUDIBLE]
latency to customers anywhere
in the world, irrespective of
their language or location.
It's a simple three-step
process to make
the most of Recommendations AI.
First, put all your data to
work by codelessly ingesting it
into the Recommendations AI by
using Google tools you already
use.
Next, select your business
goals through an intuitive
UI with just a few clicks,
and set your models to train.
And finally, serve
recommendations
anywhere in the
customer journey,
across web, mobile,
or email campaigns.
As a bonus, we automatically
retrain your models daily
to draw insights from the
changing catalogs, user
behavior, or shopping
trends, and incorporate them
into the recommendations
being served.
There are two parts to the
data that Recommendations AI
users to train
personalization models.
First, there's a
catalog of items
to recommend that includes
item descriptions, images,
categories, and price.
And second, there's
customer and event data,
that is a history of what users
have clicked on or bought.
We've made it seamless
for you to bring
your data to Recommendations
AI through a plethora of tools
you already use like Google
Tag Manager, Google Analytics
360, Google Shopping,
or BigQuery,
and are continuously
working on ways to eliminate
the need for you to write a
single line of code to do this.
For example, you can now
schedule your frequent catalog
imports from Google
Shopping to keep
your catalog of items and
Recommendations AI up to date.
We also monitor the health of
your data feed in real time,
so that you can be notified when
the data quality deteriorates.
Next, with just a few clicks in
the Recommendations AI console,
you can specify the
business objectives
you'd like to cater
your recommendations to.
First, select the
recommendation type that's
most relevant for use case.
For example, the
Recommended For You
model is our most
personalized model
that many of our customers use
in a placement on their home
page or in email campaigns.
Most customers complement
this with the Others You May
Like model, the replacement
on the product detail page,
and the Frequently
Bought Together
model through a placement
in the Add to Cart pop-up.
Next, specify your objective.
It could be maximizing
a click-through rate
on the recommendation, a
conversion rate, or revenue
per session.
And finally, choose from a
plethora of fine-tuning options
that can enable you to
do things like constrain
the recommendations to
follow certain business
or merchandising
rules, or increase
the diversification of
items being recommended,
or increase likelihood that
higher-priced items will
be recommended.
Once you hit the Create
button in the console,
in just a couple of days, your
models will be fully trained,
and you'll be able to preview
the recommendations they
are making before deploying
those recommendations
in production.
Once your models
are ready to serve,
you can leverage
Recommendations AI anywhere
in the customer journey.
Let's take a look at
one customer's journey
as an example.
A customer begins their
journey on a laptop,
browsing the sports
apparel category.
But Recommendations
AI recommend shoes.
The customer leaves, but comes
back to the site on their phone
to view more shoes.
Recommendations AI steps in
again to recommend sunglasses.
Our customer adds sunglasses
and shoes to their cart,
indicating an interest
in both items.
Here, Recommendations
AI recommends
shorts, which the
customer clicks on
to look at, but ultimately,
abandons their cart.
Three days later, you can send
a personalized follow-up email
to the customer with recommended
items based on the customer's
clicks and interests.
Recommendations AI
closes the loop,
spurring the customer to buy
sunglasses and shorts, both
recommended, based on the
customer's previous activity
across devices.
As you can see,
high-quality recommendations
can work throughout the
entire buying process,
from initial product
discovery on a laptop,
to consideration
on a mobile device,
to purchasing, followed
through via email.
With Recommendations
AI, delivering anywhere
in the customer journey
also means delivering
to any geographic region.
We're globally available, and
the API scales to your needs.
One of the things I'd
like to underscore
is how effective Recommendations
AI's deep learning
models can be at
uncovering shopper intent.
Legacy recommendation
solutions that leverage
popularity-based or
product-based algorithms
will usually anchor on
items or categories,
but miss the
opportunity to cater
to the individual shopper's
journey altogether.
Recommendations AI, on the other
hand, is truly personalized,
and looks back at the
user's shopper journey
to make recommendations to them.
That means if a user has
shown an interest in watches
in the past, even
when they are looking
at a seemingly unrelated
product like a dress,
Recommendations AI knows that
they have a high propensity
to purchase the watch, and
will recommend it to them.
And we're always iterating
and always improving.
They've made it
trivially simple to get
started with Recommendations
AI through the console.
Any Google Cloud
customer can now
enable the
Recommendations AI API,
and train and manage their
recommendation models
with just a few clicks.
We're constantly adding easier
ways to ingest your data,
such as with the recent
GA 360 integration.
We also now
automatically monitor
the quality of your data,
and give you the ability
to preview
recommendations in the UI.
Our models can now create
faster than ever before,
and are retrained daily to
make the most of the changing
patterns in your data.
We can handle massive catalogs
with tens of millions of items.
In collaboration with some
of our colleagues at Google
Research, we're
pushing the boundary
of what's possible
for recommendation
systems for retail.
As an example, some of the
work that's come out of that
has made it possible
for us to correct
for bias with popular items,
seasonality, and leverage item
metadata to make sense
of long-tail items
for which we don't have much
customer click or purchase
data.
But ultimately, all
of this technology
only matters to the extent
that it delivers results.
As we've been building and
scaling Recommendations AI,
we've worked with a
number of customers
to roll out better
recommendations
to 100% of their production
e-commerce traffic.
Along the way, we've been
able to prove our ability
to deliver a significant
lift on key business metrics
that you care about, as
shown in AV tests controlled
by our customers, versus
their previous recommendation
systems.
To talk about some
of these results,
I'd like to introduce
Brian and Graham.
Brian is the CTO of BigCommerce,
one of the largest SAS
e-commerce platforms
in the world,
and an important
Google Cloud partner.
And Graham is the CEO
of Qubit, a leader
in AI-led merchandising and
personalized experiences,
and an early adopter
of Recommendations AI.
BRIAN DHATT: Hello, everyone.
I'm Brian Dhatt, Chief
Technology Officer
at BigCommerce.
Today, I'm going to provide a
short overview of BigCommerce,
what we do, and why we're
really excited about Google
Recommendations AI.
I'll then share a
recent case study
on using Google Recommendations
AI with one of our merchants
and some of our
learnings from that.
Lastly, we'll talk about what
comes next for BigCommerce
with Google Recommendations AI.
First, to understand
who've M Commerce is,
it's important to
look at the history
of e-commerce platforms.
Typically, there
were two options
when it came to e-commerce,
open source and SAS.
Merchants that favored full
control over the architecture
and build of their
site chose open source.
Merchants that favored
simplicity and security
chose SAS.
That compromise is
really no longer
necessary with BigCommerce's
open SAS approach, which
gives brands the traditional
benefits of multi-tenant SAS,
usability, performance,
continuous upgrades,
with the flexibility
to build and innovate.
Over 90% of our
platform is exposed,
via APIs, which gives
brands the ability
to extend the platform to
existing tools and solutions
that they might use,
or build completely
custom solutions to
complex problems.
Not only do we provide
these capabilities,
but we take it a step
further by investing heavily
in integrations with
best of breed solutions
and emerging technologies,
like AI, for example.
It's because of our API-driven
architecture and best
of breed approach that we're
here today talking about Google
Recommendations AI.
Let's take a closer look
why this integration
is so exciting for us.
When we combine Google's
incredible AI technology
with BigCommerce's powerful
e-commerce platform,
incredible things
become possible.
We use AI technology to enable
merchants to easily automate
parts of their
merchandising strategy.
Shoppers benefit from being
able to more easily discover
products that they
love, even when
they're browsing through
very large product catalogs.
To prove the efficacy of
Google's AI functionality,
we started partnering with the
brand Woolrich and their agency
MoJo Active.
We created an A/B
test where half
of the shoppers on woolrich.com
got the incumbent experience,
where the Related
Products section was
powered by a search algorithm.
The other half of shoppers
got the same visual design,
but we used Google's
Recommendations AI
to determine which related
products would show up.
Our objective was to increase
the click through rate
on related products and,
ultimately, revenue.
The results are fantastic.
With Google
Recommendations AI, we
increased the click through rate
by 28% on the Related Products
module, but delivered
an amazing 269%
increase in revenue among
the cohort of shoppers
engagement with the related
product recommendations.
Said differently,
this is the revenue
from shoppers purchasing related
products that they clicked on.
We believe this is just
the beginning of what's
possible to help shoppers
discover products they'll love,
and to help merchants
efficiently and profitably grow
their business.
The integration we built
starts by ingesting data
into Google's AI platform.
This included the merchant's
product catalog, as well as
three months of historical
product page view events
for an initial model training.
We continually updated Google
with product catalog data
and product page view data to
keep the machine learning model
up to date, and selected
the Others You May
Like model for the
product detail placement.
Once this model was
built and trained,
we wrapped the Google
predictions API
into a BigCommerce API.
All aspects of the
integration to Google's AI
are managed by us
within our GCP account.
Because Woolrich is running
their store in BigCommerce
and we handle the
data integration,
Woolrich's agency,
MoJo Active, was
able to get Woolrich
live easily and quickly
with powerful technology, using
a very simple BigCommerce API.
While the results
were fantastic,
we discovered a few
challenges along the way.
Let's take a look at
some of the learnings
and where we're headed next.
One challenge that
surprised us was
how pervasive and
sophisticated bots had become.
We found that over
40% of site traffic
was generated from bots.
And this was a
mixture of good bots
that identify themselves
and their user agent data,
as well as bad bots that
pretended to be human visitors.
Filtering out the bots
became critical to ensure
that we train the ML model
on human generated data,
and to ensure we had accurate
reporting on the A/B test.
We used two methods to
improve our bot filtering.
One was to improve our use
of user [INAUDIBLE] data,
and the other was to
require JavaScript execution
to trigger events,
as older bots don't
tend to support JavaScript.
In regards to the A/B
testing that we set up,
we found this to be an
incredibly valuable way
to learn fast on what is
and what isn't working,
and ultimately, to prove the
efficacy of the solution,
and the great results we
achieved with Woolrich.
We are extremely excited about
the results we've seen together
with Woolrich.
We're now looking to bring
Google Recommendations
AI to more merchants on
the BigCommerce platform.
And we're expanding the depth
and breadth of our integration
with Google Recommendations AI.
If you're interested in
learning more about creating
personalized shopping
experiences on BigCommerce,
please visit us today at
bigcommerce.com/googlenext.
Thanks for spending a
few minutes with me.
And now with that, I'll
turn it over to Graham.
GRAHAM COOKE: Thank you, Brian.
Thank you, Pallav.
Hi, thanks for all your time.
My name's Graham Cooke.
I'm CEO and founder of Qubit.
Excited to be presenting
to all of you today.
I guess this is the new normal
to be presenting from my home
at these wonderful
conferences like Google Next.
But I'm really
excited to take you
through how the Qubit
clients are using the Google
Recommendations AI platform, one
of most exciting technologies
we've been working
with in a long time.
So I think it goes
without saying,
we're reaching the tipping point
for digital first commerce.
This really means that what I'm
seeing, across our client base,
is that there's just more
and more confirmation
that we've got to be operating
with the digital first
strategy.
If you're multi-channel
retailer, you've, in the past,
been thinking about
your biggest stores.
And you've been
thinking about how
to look at everything
at a store-first model,
a product-first model.
But really what
we're seeing now,
it's a digital first model.
More and more businesses
are talking about that.
How do we work from digital?
And stores are
just, essentially,
an arm of digital
first commerce.
What's driving this is the fact
that it's just gotten massively
accelerated.
It's been a really
hard six months.
I know all of us
have really found
it challenging to be
trading in these times.
But ultimately, what
we've seen, though,
is a 10-year leap
in 90 days' time.
And that's a 10-year leap in
the penetration of e-commerce.
And we're now up in
that 30 to 35-plus
of total online
spending in e-commerce.
And it's incredibly exciting.
I mean, what we're
seeing is pure plays
are doing better than
they've ever done.
Multi-channel
retailers have never
seen more sales on e-commerce.
And, really, what all of
our clients are saying to us
is, how do we keep
up this performance?
How do we keep the digital
channel performing so well?
And so what I always talk to
the market, and our customers,
and the industry about
is that, really, part
of this tipping point,
digital commerce experiences
are surpassing the
in-store experience.
And really, that's because the
digital commerce experience
is powered by AI.
The site truly
knows who you are.
It's able to understand you.
It's able to guide you
through the journey.
It's helping you find the
things and discover the things
you might not have ever found.
And simply walking into a
store, you don't get that.
You don't have that
assistance, when
you're walking
through the store,
in the same way,
because that store has
been built for
everybody who came
into the physical location.
And the people in that
store don't know you
deeply in many cases.
And so you just don't get
as great an experience.
I find myself walking to
stores now and thinking,
this takes so long
to find what I need,
compared to how well it
works to shop on many
of our customers' sites.
So Qubit focuses
on driving growth
by focusing on
relevance for leading
retail businesses within
fashion, luxury, health
and beauty, grocery.
And really what our
customers are doing,
is they're using personalization
and AI-led merchandising
technology to focus on driving
relevance for their customer.
And by providing more
relevant customer experiences,
those customers spend
more, and come back,
and become more loyal.
And our customers
are able to continue
to be leaders, and continue
to advance as the trendsetting
brands in the industry.
So I'm going to talk about
one of the experiences
that our customer is
using around the AI-led
recommendations, in one
of the most notoriously
difficult parts to
do a recommendation
model, the basket page.
Now typically, with
your non-one-to-one,
your crowd-based models
for recommendations,
you show a recommendation
in the basket.
You're probably going
to drive conversion
down significantly because
you're ultimately distracting
your customer as they're ready
to check out with something
less relevant, potentially.
Nobody's been doing
one-to-one in the basket.
And so in many cases,
conversion has gone down.
Maybe basket values have
gone up to make up for it,
but it hasn't been that good.
What we've seen with using
Google Recommendations
AI in the basket, is
we've seen a 5% increase
in revenue per visitor.
Almost the same conversion
rate, but a big increase in
add to baskets.
And really, what this
is the equivalent of,
for the first time, and
you're applying it to luxury,
you're applying it to
fashion, you're applying it
to health and beauty,
is you're creating
that impulsive, at the
checkout purchase opportunity,
just like when you're in
an actual physical store,
and they've put all the items
near the checkout for you
to just pick them up
and put them on the till
as you're leaving.
So this is the
equivalent of impulsive,
completely personalized,
and not distracting.
And it's driving 5%.
Just one recommendation
model carousel doing 5%.
And typically what
our clients will do,
is they will actually
implement between 5
and 15 various different
AI-powered personalization
recommendations carousels
across their site,
their app, their emails.
And the cumulative impact
of this is getting it to be
20%-25% of additional sales from
bringing all these different
strategies together.
And really, what our
clients across the base,
as they're using more
true one-to-one, is
they're playing that back to us.
They're saying, for the
first time have we actually
seen what one-to-one
recommendations,
one-to-one personalization
does for revenue.
It drives more revenue
than we've ever
been able to drive before.
And really, what I'm
seeing is this leap
from where we've
been all these years.
We've just been stuck
underneath this impact barrier.
And now we're able
to break through this
with the real AI, real
individualization at scale.
And it's thanks to platforms
like Google Recommendations AI
that we're really
able to do this.
And what we want to
give for our customers,
we want to give
them the combination
of the power of the
Google Recommendations AI.
But we want to give them within
the merchandising Control
Suite, so that they can
control how the recommendation
system will actually
work, how they can exclude
certain products, include other
products, the type of model
they want to use, and exactly
how it's going to look,
based on the different page
templates and strategies.
And this is the relationship
between merchandisers
and the AI that we think allows
merchandising teams to really
just accelerate, and
become more proactive,
and become the great
merchandisers they are, and not
have to be constantly
working behind the customer.
They're working
ahead of the customer
with this type of technology.
And then we marry that
up with other types
of personalized content, other
type of badging, scarcity,
all within a single
easy-to-use platform.
And so under the
hood, what's actually
happening is Qubit is providing
a clean, contextually-relevant
data feed, in real time, to
the Google Recommendations AI.
And so what that really
looks like, here on the left,
is it's an
industry-specific taxonomy.
So whether you're in
fashion, or you're
in luxury, or health
and beauty, or grocery,
we have an event-based taxonomy,
specific to your industry.
And that allows you to feed
this deep, contextual, real time
flow of information about
customers, about products,
about transactions into the deep
learning AI system by the API.
And then all the
learning and the training
happens on an
individual customer,
at an individual shopper
at the brand level.
And that's what starts to create
this incredible recommendation
system that, then, flows
back into that merchandising
and experience workflow tool.
So the merchandiser can
control how it's going to look.
They can control the rules.
And most important, they
can measure the results
and understand if this
type of personalization
is effective at driving
sales or conversions,
and helping to
grow the business.
And then this is a
constant feedback loop,
from merchandiser feeding
context back into the system,
and that goes back into the
recommendations learning
system.
And so we've been a partner
of Google Cloud for over five
years, and we've
never looked back.
It's the most phenomenal
cloud platform.
It's the most advanced for
handling real time data
systems like this.
And it's the only
way we could have
scaled what we've built for all
of our hundreds of customers.
And really what we're
handling here, at peak,
is 120,000 events per second.
We are processing
enormous amounts
of information on
the peak sales days
that we're all coming
up to in holiday.
It takes us, as
well, just a second
to take all that real
time information that's
just flowing through it,
that hundreds of thousands
per second, and put that
into the systems that
will be key to how the data
is trained within the Google
Recommendations AI,
such as BigQuery.
And typically, our
customers are sending
120,000 different attributes,
customer attributes,
product attributes into the
system for the machine learning
to do its magic.
And really, I believe
that deep learning AI
is going to disrupt retail like
we've never seen it before.
The next two years are
going to be the biggest
shift we've seen in
e-commerce since the beginning
of e-commerce.
And it's all
happening right now.
AI is going to be at
the heart of that.
And the Google Cloud
Recommendations AI platform
is the way to do this.
And we'd be really
excited to take you
through how to use that
with the Qubit platform.
So we're in the Google
Cloud marketplace,
or alternatively, reach out
to your Google Cloud account
manager, or contact us
directly at info@quibit.com.
We'd love to talk to you.
We'd love to hear
about your business.
And I'll say thank you
very much to everybody
and thank you Pallav,
and thank you Brian.